scp-035 vs scp-1000  could the boundlessly malevolent  possessive mask fend off against a  specimen of scp-1000 aka bigfoot a large  and extremely advanced race of apes  scp-1000 in their prime is undeniably  more powerful than a single human these  giant nocturnal apes have both  impressive physical strength as well as  intelligence and wisdom great enough to  build hyper-advanced societies while  humans were still killing each other  with rocks however seeing as the  brainwaves of scp-1000 don't differ that  greatly from humans it wouldn't be a  stretch for the mask to manipulate one  of them into putting it on a single  scp-1000 specimen would be no match for  the terrifying scp-035  when the mask goes on it's curtains